the swamp itself is steeped in mystery
holding a wildness that is so
increasingly rare in modern life there's
this very like ghost-like thing dancing
off the edge of a tree it just deepens
the mystery it deepens the power of
those places there's just nothing like
it the way has these curling tendrils
and that long nectar stem the artistry
is in the form itself
[Music]
there are so few of them there so
endangered and I'm so elusive we hardly
know anything about them we all have
this inherent desire to know the answers
this is something that is in our
backyard that science doesn't know yet
what pollinates the ghost orchid you
know this is the burning question that
has outlasted generations of scientists
this summer we're like you know what if
we're gonna do this we got to go always
this team that's going about it in
different ways we are about 50 feet in a
cypress tree Carlton is having to wade
through waist-deep water and then paddle
board miles and heads the chase of this
photo is definitely pushing all of us
it's like near breaking point I don't
actually know the ingredients of
obsession maybe it's the chance of
trying something that seems impossible
[Music]
[Music]
orchids are the most diverse group of
flowering plants in the world they're
about 25-30 thousand species
the most iconic orchid pollination story
is one that Darwin was interested in 150
years ago and it involves an orchid in
Madagascar that has a nectar tube that's
over a foot long and Darwin had
predicted that a moth must have a tongue
that's that matches the length of the
nectar tube this thing was so extreme
that his expression was good heavens
what insect is sucking here in South
Florida it's the most diverse place for
orchids in the United States and so was
really drawn to the ghost orchid because
how little was known about it it's all
about this game that enchantment you
know it's this nondescript twig like
leafless plant growing on the side of a
cypress tree until it pushes this
ephemeral ghost-like flower for the sole
purpose of attracting a pollinator
[Music]
a super specific flower adapted in
co-evolved
to a super specific pollinator it's
always been suspected that the giant
sphinx moth pollinates the ghost orchid
based on the size of the moth the length
of the tongue in a scientific sense we
need to prove that this is the perfect
embodiment of the scientific process
here's a theory let's put it to the test
[Music]
Mack and I had been talking about trying
to photograph ghosts or kids being
pollinated going back to 2014 here's how
I'm gonna try to do it and the idea is
actually to use camera traps and sleep
out in a swamp for however long it takes
the hard part to though is that the
ghost like the way those roots are and
how old it is is all over that that's
got to be a 50 year old orchid by the
size of those roots the ghost orchid
here in corkscrew swamp they've called
the super ghost and that is because it
produces so many flowers every single
year it is a mass of roots that just
spider out in all directions and it's
not just one bloom it's not two blooms
it can get up to sixteen blings at a
time which is insane I got but indi it's
a non-stop moth party or I hope it is
into this swamp
you got everything yeah ready we were
started undertaking this project that
called Peter who is an expert in orchids
who worked for years on pollination
attempts Peters an animal he actually
went out in the swamp for weeks at a
time and stood on a ladder aiming an
infrared video camera had a ghost orchid
patrolling different flowers hoping
something would come it was so
frustrating for so long that I was
almost just ready to walk away from the
whole thing and then Mack Carlton we're
kind of like you know yeah we were meant
to do this we've got to do this all
right let's do it
I was ascending and Mac was coming up as
well and he looked up the trunk and just
saw a giant sphinx moth
they're so camouflaged I don't I have no
idea how Mac even spotted it the mall
sitting right there and we're kind of
wondering you know is the Sun gonna set
and this thing is it gonna take off and
fly right to the orchid and pollinate it
tonight might be the night
[Music]
these ancient canopies that used to
extend all over the southeast they hold
an entire ecosystem this ghost orchid is
a relic of that ecosystem of how it used
to be I think for Mack the chance to
come here to corkscrew to go to this
amazing ghost orchid and try to put a
camera trap there is something no one
even thought of doing and so while I'm
having to climb up 50 feet to see and
photograph mine Carlton is by water
trying to make this image happen we're
kind of on parallel pursuits to try to
answer this question part of the
obsession for me the biggest part of the
intrigue is where this orchid lives
because these are the wildest most
inaccessible places we have left in the
state of Florida arguably in the East
there are these deep flooded remote
swamps twisted and gnarled trunks
forming these cathedrals it's dark it's
green it feels like you're in the Amazon
or in some other world
waiting waist deep amongst alligators
Panthers bears it's really easy to get
really wild really remote really quick
we are getting wanna buy downpour here
actually love it and they range like
this it feels like the cloth come to
life I kind of do too I wouldn't be
surprised if we get an inch of rain and
we can actually see this swamp ride
there's a really strange fervor about
these orchids I didn't understand it at
first but I used to say they those
people that are crazy about this effort
I not to say we because I'm doing things
that I would never do I stay up at night
I cannot sleep the ghost orchid frenzy
is a real one intent of these ghosts irk
is actually produce a flower each year
and of those one in ten actually get
pollinated so if you stack up the odds
you need to have to put out ten cameras
on 10 different blooms to have a
probability of one moth coming the moths
are so rare is there even a moths in the
vicinity that could pollinate this
there's a reason why it hasn't been
documented before that's because it's
really really difficult
[Music]
craziest thing just happened I was
looking down changing out my battery and
then pop the camera went off ten times I
thought it was a false trigger and I
looked up in like 12 inches from my face
there is a Maw sitting on the orchid
flower scrolling through literally
thousands of photographs you had itty
bitty mobs they were just kind of
hovering in space medium sized mods
landing on the flower but no capability
to get any nectar as a reward there's
one photo where the orchid just bounces
out of the frame down and out of the
frame up I'm like what in the world is
going on and there's a little frog that
was hanging off of it so you're getting
like this window into this microcosm
that happens around this bloom so let's
keep these cameras going let's see what
we have after the end of a couple of
months
just the ones that are about to open is
one two three four but then I count
eight more after these four see what
this baby's gonna go up get to the
camera I hit play and I start scrolling
through images and I remember my heart
jumping yeah what he's right across from
me and I said Peter I've got I've got
one orange on the flanges he's like what
I was like orange on the wings he looks
at this [ __ ] he goes dude you have the
first ever photo of a giant sphinx moth
at a ghost orchid
[Music]
so you have this elongated body of the
giant Sphinx kind of arcing back and
then it's wings are spread and hovering
and its proboscis is out right in front
of the orchids and it's just sitting
there it's like it was just this is just
place there there are multiple frames of
this giant Sphinx and I started looking
at them closely zoomed in and looked at
the face of this moth and it is covered
just covered with a different kind of
pollen plenty of most likely from a moon
vine and I'm looking at it even closer
and I'm thinking wow you know it's got
its proboscis all the way into this
flower and yet its face is still an inch
or two inches out of the flower could it
be that the giant Sphinx actually has a
proboscis that is almost too long to get
its face into the orchid could it be
that the giant Sphinx it's actually
robbing nectar from this flower Peter
and I were both like you know this kind
of turns the whole theory on its on its
head this existing idea that this was
the only pollinator it's perhaps not
actually providing any benefit at all to
the flower and that was a wild moment
the discovery opens up this whole new
kind of Pandora's box there are all
these other things that add more
questions we as humans like a simple
story but it seems that at least in this
case reality is a little more complex in
our 5 in the morning
1:00 in the morning 10:00 p.m. I cycle
through a couple more nights and all of
a sudden BAM
there is a huge moth right on the lip of
this ghost dodging he's huge
[Music]
there's a moth that was bigger than
anything I expected to see it has so
much weight when it lands it like this
brings the orchid down out of frame and
then back a moth of that species visited
this orchid three times so I shared
these with Peter and colleagues and
that's when everyone started to get
really excited he's like so this is a
giant Sphinx and I was like no and he
was just like damn and I was like dude
that's way more into it like this was
never even suspected before you know
like I'd never even thought of that fig
Sphinx being appalling
there's Pinilla on the face that's like
that's the money shot these discoveries
basically are unprecedented each photo
that Mack and Carlton get lends a new
perspective into the behavior and it's
not just about ghosts now pollination is
critical to our livelihoods good old
Chuck Darwin it would be proud of us yes
there is a physical image at the end of
the day but it is the journey of getting
to that that is what's so rewarding
especially in a place that we care so
much about
[Music]
over the past three years dozens of
trips hundreds of hours I've fallen in
love of these very specific corners of
these remote swamps we still have these
truly wild stories that the rest of the
world doesn't know about
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]